Росія відкрито завдає ударів по українській енергетиці.
Через це міста занурюються в темряву, тисячі людей залишаються без світла, води й тепла.
З 10 по 21 жовтня російські ракети і дрони нанесли близько 400 ударів
по українських об'єктах енергетики. Під час останнього масованого обстрілу 31 жовтня
постраждали 18 об'єктів у 10 регіонах.
Володимир Зеленський на зустрічі з єврокомісаркою з питань енергетики Кадрі Сімсон
заявив, що пошкоджено 40 відсотків усієї енергетичної інфраструктури України.
Здебільшого постраждали НЕ генеруючі потужності.
Електростанції - це доволі міцні й захищені споруди, які непросто зруйнувати обстрілами.
Тож вони продовжують виробляти струм.
За даними Центру досліджень енергетики, загалом енергокомплекс України
здатен видавати 50 ГВт електроенергії.
Близько 11 ГВт - це потужності на окупованих територіях.
Тоді як пікова потреба споживачів нині - 13 ГВт.
Але російські ракети б'ють переважно по розподільчих підстанціях.
Через це вироблений струм стає неможливо доставити до споживачів.
Атакується система транспортування електрики.
Себто якщо так провести аналогію, то атакуються хайвеї,
по яких передається електроенергія.
На думку експертів, мета російських обстрілів - розбити енергосистему України на окремі сегменти.
Фактично створити окремі "острівці" в енергосистемі, де той чи інший район
матимуть профіцит електричної енергії, а інший регіон буде мати дефіцит електричної енергії.
І саме ці злочинні цільові удари унеможливлюють перетік електричної енергії
з регіону профіцитного за наявністю електричної енергії до регіону
з дефіцитом електричної енергії.
У Міненерго зазначають, що росіяни б'ють по об'єктах, які відновлювати найважче.
Деякі підстанції руйнують заново вже після ремонту.
Найбільша проблема нині - обладнання на підстанціях. Воно дороге й виготовляється під замовлення.
Подекуди треба чекати до дев'яти місяців. У групі ДТЕК заявили, що запас обладнання
на їхніх складах уже вичерпано.
Утім, Олександр Харченко, який залучений до переговорів з ЄС
про енергетичну допомогу, запевняє, що Європа попри низку труднощів
готова допомагати Україні з технікою й запчастинами.
Особливості української енергосистеми в тому числі полягають у використанні
нами ліній в 750 кіловольт, найпотужніших, а Європа не використовує лінії
вище, ніж 400 кіловольт. Тому певні класи обладнання взагалі відсутні
в складському режимі навіть на аварійних складах.
Але сьогодні ми просто бачимо, як партнери часом навіть ідуть на послаблення
свого резервування для того, щоб швидше нам допомогти.
За словами експертів, оскільки Європа останнім часом відмовлялася
від теплових електростанцій, у ЄС можуть бути запаси вживаного обладнання.
В українському МЗС повідомили, що домовилися про поставки
енергетичного обладнання з 12 країн.
Україна має технічну можливість імпортувати струм з Європи.
Однак у цьому питанні є багато "але".
Після початку повномасштабного вторгнення українська енергосистема
синхронізувалася з європейською. Після цього Україна почала експортувати
електроенергію в Європу, адже виробляла більше, ніж споживала.
Продавати український струм у Європі можна було дорожче, тож це було
вигідно для трейдерів. А от купувати європейську електрику тепер доведеться
за вдвічі вищими цінами.
Можна також попросити у Євросоюзу про аварійну допомогу.
Струм надаватиметься безкоштовно. Але такий самий обсяг електроенергії
за певний час треба буде повернути Європі.
Крім того, пропускні спроможності України щодо імпорту струму
з Європи технічно обмежені.
Вони становлять приблизно 500 мегават.
Цього звісно недостатньо, тому що, наприклад, лише одне промислове підприємство
споживає або потребує потужність для своєї повноцінної роботи 40 мегават.
Тому ми можемо оцінити, що аварійні можливості є, але вони доволі обмежені.
Під тотальним блекаутом енергетики розуміють повну некерованість
енергетичної системи. Нині до цього ще далеко, стверджують аналітики.
Разом з тим коли саме українська енергетика перетне межу стійкості - невідомо,
адже удари по енергосистемі такого масштабу відбуваються в історії вперше.
Тотальний блекаут - це повний розпад енергосистеми, який за собою веде
до багаточисельних технологічних катастроф. І якщо відбудеться реальний блекаут,
це буде означати, що аби просто перезапустити наші генераційні потужності
і перезапустити мережу знадобиться два тижні щонайменше.
Опитані DW експерти не вважають такий сценарій імовірним.
Але визнають, що перейти на газ там, де це можливо, не буде зайвим.
Газотранспортна система менш піддатлива і вразлива.
Якщо є можливість домогосподарств України, якщо є можливість
у промислових підприємствах, комерційних установах замістити хоча б частково
використання електричної енергії, наприклад, тим самим природним газом
- це потрібно зробити.
Водночас у Міненерго наголошують, що запорукою стабільності
української енергосистеми будуть додаткові системи протиповітряної оборони.
Їх Київ теж очікує від західних партнерів.